favi risponde fa vive viti un bicchiere
di kriptonite liquidare sogna di
diventare un divo di hollywood che cazzo
hai fumato zio chiesti ragazzi la
kryptonite non è facile da preparare e
ciò che so ma che è stato zeri ah vabbè
alla salute regalo
[Musica]
am è stato un sogno più a picco della
storia lega
devo andare la cina asciugamano per
farlo porca sono distrutto
purtroppo i sogni sono solo sogni però
che cosa cazzo c'era qua dentro
vado a prendere un attimo un asciugamano
che sto messo leggermente male
quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fatti j
oggi siamo in un nuovo blog allora
ragazzi prima di cominciare volevo dirvi
che in questo blog
voglio fare soltanto il fa vi risponde
per questa volta perché come l'avete
chiesto in tanti ce tipo il commento
quello favi fai solo
ecco siccome ho fatto quello che ho
fatto solo scattato dei pacchi con
l'hanno capito perché faccio così ogni
volta che dico pacchi prova beh voglio
fare quello dove faccio solo il fa vi
risponde quindi ragazzi prima di
cominciare a ripartire cosa fate la
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da silvia che ha fatto star o mio
dio santa questo questa ragazzi non è
una fan a questo è gesù all'inizio
pensavo che avesse preso una immagine
già fatta e ci avesse appiccicato il mio
logo sul sul petto invece no è tutta
fatta così veloci anche sito fa vj ti
voglio bene grazie di cuore per questo
capolavoro assoluto
non so veramente cosa dire veramente
grazie detto questo ragazzini che
possiamo passare alle news volevo dirvi
una roba che siccome stati ma ne è
uscito un casino volevo spiegarvi che
cosa sta succedendo alla siccome motivo
e mi hanno detto fammi ma è vero che fai
un libro sta scrivendo un libro fa vi è
vero che farei un film
forlì è vero che andrei sulla luna fa vi
è vero che farai un album di figurine è
tutto vero tutto anche quello della
luiss sono cose vere che sto portando
avanti da circa un annetto solo che non
avevo mai detto perché è in teoria volo
che fosse una sorpresa però non ve l'ho
mai detto ma è da circa un anno che
stavo progettando di fare questa cosa
vado con ordine allora per il film il
latte vero ragazzi forum farò un film si
è visto nell'intervista video comunque
va no vabbè farò veramente un film
perché non un film tipo cinepanettoni
italiani breve tutta quella gente
no è un film proprio americane senso
registi americani è tutta una roba tipo
inception no vabbè comunque è una roba
non è una roba del cazzo infatti
show l'ansia già da adesso comunque
molti mi dicono falli ma non è che se
fai film poi non fai più video è una
cosa che mi porto avanti da un annetto
circa quindi non vi preoccupate c'è
tranquillissimi ragazzi non lascerò mai
youtube perché vedo che motivo il mio
andrè messaggi fare è vero che lascia
youtube tra non so quanto tempo
no ragazzi non lascerò mai perché io ho
iniziato a fare video non mi ricordo
quando è stato il mio primo video su
youtube e risale anche
2007 addirittura non ero io fa dj ma
mette ovito a caso perché metto video
dal 2007 su youtube io faccio la
youtuber però da dal 2011 circa quindi
youtube a parte il fatto che col passare
tempo magari diventato anche un lavoro
lo so però per me you tube è sempre
stata una passione può diventare quello
che vuole una passione rimane c'è una
cosa un po come un calciatore che gioca
a calcio e gli piace giocare poi magari
va a giocare in serie a perchè c'è un
però per me è stato più o meno lo stesso
nel senso mi diverto e se è diventato
non lo so se farò questi in futuro però
bìdoli farò sempre sempre quindi non vi
preoccupate ragazzi vostro fa vigilo
avrete sempre sempre quindi non vi
preoccupate questo discorso ci tenevo a
farvelo per quanto riguarda la mondi
figurine sia un anno fa sempre la prima
aveva chiesto se volevo fare un album e
io ho detto sì kat
non c'è una cosa in cui ricordò quando
facevo cieli ancora non li prendo perché
se non ci metto 20 minuti la play
cassetta e comunque ragazzi una cosa che
siccome richiede tantissimo lavoro
perché lo stanno facendo un casino di
tempo per me è un onore
e assurdo cioè in un po te posso ancora
crederci questa cosa comunque va beh e
per quanto riguarda il libro in realtà
si perché io allora fermi state le
siccome io leggo parecchio anche se non
lo dà a vedere leggo tipo libri non
faccio vedere io che sono è pubblicità
non faccio vedere niente io leggo
abbastanza perché mi piace e sfogare
tanto s'è visto prima quindi one andato
tutto a averla virgolette ho
provato anche iniziare a scrivere ho
scoperto mi piace veramente tanto cioè
io in italiano me la sono sempre cavata
bene con l'ultima prof un po ci ho fatto
a cazzotti prova me anche quando
facciamo i temi ad esempio andavo a
scuola alle medie superiori ho sempre
fatto romanzi assurdi tra l'altro a
volte gli facevo anche due palle così
alle prove infatti ci avevano sempre due
forse non lo so ma credo di sì perché mi
stanno arrivando ottime news
forse ce la fanno anche a pubblicarle
per me sarebbe certo se mettiamo insieme
tutte queste tre cose che ho detto per
me io ho raggiunto il massimo della mia
soddisfazione io sono veramente
veramente veramente contento ma
veramente contento
e se non fosse stato per voi ragazzi non
avrei mai potuto fare una cosa del
genere perché
non avrei mai avuto ispirazione avrei
neanche niente da raccontare perché io
racconterò ovviamente di quello che è
successo da quando ho aperto il canale e
quindi non avrei non sarebbe mai
successo tutto questo quindi ragazzi
veramente io non troverò mai le parole
di giuro che lo sto dicendo senza tagli
si fa nulla perché questa cosa è chiara
veramente grazie per tutto il supporto
che mi avete sempre dato che mi state
continuando a dare e io vi darò sempre
soddisfazioni nel caso avviate una
brutta giornata cosa del genere voi
cercate io ci sarò sempre promesso posso
fare un taglio si cazzo non lo so merita
solo col discorso ed ai basta più su
pallosu finite per quanto riguarda alle
isole action sono rifatto fino a quel
punto è questa settimana ragazzi di
parte anche anni di isole shaun quindi
basta a travasare i maroni ok ultima
roba e poi passiamo al fa vi risponde
perché voglio fare solo alla fine è
diventato un blog solo di news
praticamente perché non faccio tagli
quindi viene lungo due chilometri e
normale che i ragazzi per quanto
riguarda gli speciali che non faccio da
un bel pezzo state tranquilli che
ritorneranno anche quelli perché tipo
momenti epici e da secoli che non ne
faccio uno quindicenne un miliardo di
momenti epici posso farmi 56 di video
con i ragazzi aspettatevi di tutto è
detto questo finito con le news di oltre
avanzati maroni sì l'ho fatto basta
direi che possiamo passare al fuori
risponde solo farli risponde prima
domanda fini risponde inizi fare
risponde col tuo cappello preferito ma
siccome volevo dare un tono a questo fa
vi risponde evitare che venisse rovinata
dalla marmotta morta con in testa anche
detta capelli ho messo il cappello e
siamo a posto
pur tra mille favi risposta ma favi
risposta no non fare risparmi risposta
ma se si sono i musulmani perché non
esistono imu sul piede lo vedi questo
piegati un attimino chiudi gli occhi non
tardino ragazzi perché non c'è un
cree pane a questa è la frase
che ho detto nello scorso blog ragazzi
perché c'è un clipper nel mio
pacco non andateci a letto ve lo
sconsiglio
e i favi allora arriviamo al dunque ha
voglia si aspetta un attimo che aspetta
ehi ma che cos'è qui poi risponde farvi
quando ti sei fatto vedere da tua madre
se ti sei fatto vedere come ha reagito
ballarò guardami qua guardò seriamente
perché dici perché vedi tu noi la sto
vivendo
guardami qua sto guardando
ha reagito così dai non mi mettono i
video
no non ti mettono e video fa vi risponde
farvi casatenovo prendi tutta la musica
che metti nei video è una roba allora
ragazzi praticamente io c'ho wind sul
telefono mi lasciano tipo 25 milioni di
brani a caso c'è nomi miliardo che la
smettono mai praticamente perché gli
otto wind quindi con un'offerta ciò la
vita pratica intenda sterzo tutto
praticamente la musica che voglia quando
la trovo la presente la regola la metto
nei video direttamente il pavimento e lo
faccio così già che ci sono non vi
dispiace mi metto ascoltare nel
leggermente un po di musica non mi
chiedete vino ve l'ho messo perché non
c'è un ore
comunque io vado alla prossima grazie
[Musica]
i sistemi mi chiamava puntiglioso blog
stiamo qua tutto ciò la domanda da
frankie non è mai tanto la facciata
frankie centi la faccia da maria
giovanna poi risponde ai delle sport ora
ci hai delle sparaci gli enormi graf no
questi sono i capelli
graziato invece hai un enorme dizionario
grande edizione così quasi 10 6 favi
sentimenti un grissino su per il culo
esce un mikado
[Musica]
sa proprio di merda kevin mastrojeni fi
risponde inizio e vito mangiando una
fetta di limone nel video già iniziato
secoli fa concreta la mangio lo stesso
non ho idea della reazione non l'ho mai
giuro non l'ho mai fatto quindi non lo
so e mi fa dire stronzate
[Musica]
con le lacrime agli occhi che cazzo è
possibile non si vede probabilmente mal
di stomaco ma le grazie di avermi fatto
grazie grazie veramente bart simpson fa
vi risponde ciò ancora i rimasugli del
limone del gusto che mi sta dando un
fastidio che non avete idea poi risponde
ti piace leggere se sì che preferisci ps
se una fava fantastica continua così
allora io in realtà leggo mi piacciono
molto i fantasy nel senso tipo harry
potter
oppure come i trainer hunger games
questo mi voleva uccidere shadowhunters
percy jackson mi piace tutto quel genere
di mi piace tantissimo è niente sono
questi comunque fava e tua sorella
metti che questa è la limone questo era
il secondo non avete visto non l'ho
mangiato metti chi è a ok skinny genes
fa vi risponde che bel sorriso che hai
ok non è una domanda ma è comunque un
bel sorriso
[Musica]
risponde favi potresti impersonare il
protagonista di un film di un trailer e
dire le battute al posto suo inizia con
quello di bigg hero 6
se ti piace con questo mi piace continua
che mi fate fare queste cose
ciao io sono gay ma se piacere io sono
fa vigeva un interesse dirty ma c'è
gente comunque piacere ho sentito un
verso di dolori dimmi qual è il problema
verso di dolore no io non so gente qui
ma io di sicuro non ero in una scala da
1 a 10
come va antico doloretto sono bene stai
tranquillo fai meno 10
sto da dio grazie
tu sei caduto io non sono caduto non
stavo cercando una posizione più comoda
sto bene dove max era caduto ma io io no
adesso torno giù posso league e le idee
malsane proprio nel cervello alessandro
mazza fa vi risponde se ho capito bene
se il figlio unico
in realtà sta cosa non è proprio
benissimo anche perché sì perché in
verità ci sarei anch'io e è in realtà ci
sarei anch'io
e se per caso loro due fossero non
fossero delle copie ma semplicemente
fossero miei fratelli gemelli uguali
identici m e quindi in realtà ci fossero
tre fa vj e non paola caliandro fare
risponde affari ma sei un vampiro
hai la pelle bianca e non agli specchi
in camera allora io non è che perché
adesso sono bianco e non rispecchi in
camera
cazzo
[Musica]
io so cosa sai dirlo ad alta voce bella
e tutti ragazzi ma vi risponde fare
l'ultimo qual è l'ultimo film che hai
visto al cinema i raggiunto l'ultimo
film in assoluto e l'ho visto ieri ed è
stato lì ho visto ogni maledetto natale
l'ultimo in assoluto che ho visto mi è
piaciuto un casino è piaciuta molto la
tematica tipo le due famiglie che
vogliono ognuna deve fare vuole fare il
natale a modo suo è permesso tutto
abbastanza divertente comunque questo è
stato l'ultimo figlio visto c'è guzzanti
che è uno dei miei temi a me piace
proprio come comico e mio padre che mi
ha fatto piacere così tanto la chiamo
comunque tutto il cinema in generale
l'accordo ragazzine che posso concludere
qui vi cazzo d'accordo ragazzi re che
posso concludere qui il video spero che
vi sia piaciuto anche perché ho voluto
fare questa cosa dei favi risponde
perchè non andate chiesta da un casino
di tempo quanto riguarda la fuori
domanda ragazzi ma secondo voi ci sono
veramente tre famiglie in uno solo denti
alla risposta perché potreste trovare
brutte sorprese
ragazzi come al solito c'è video è
piaciuto lasciato momento mi piace anche
a pacciani facebook è come la vita tra
te la descrizione se la vorresti dire
temi ci vediamo al prossimo video delle
ragazze